THE "WASHINGTON POST" IS NOW
REPORTING THAT FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS RUSHING TO ASSEMBLE A
TEAM OF VETERAN LAWYERS TO
DEFEND HIM FROM POTENTIAL
CRIMINAL EXPOSURE AFTER
CONFIDENTIAL DOCUMENTS WERE
RECOVERED FROM HIS FLORIDA HOME
BUT KEEPS GETTING REJECTED.
WE KNOW OF TWO HIGH PROFILE
LAWYERS REPRESENTING TRUMP,
KEVIN O'CONNOR AND JIM TRUSTY A
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
TRUMP AND HIS ALLIES HAVE PUT
FORTH A NUMBER OF ARGUMENTS
FOLLOWING THE SEARCH.
LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT THOSE
ARGUMENTS AND HOW EFFECTIVE THEY
MIGHT BE.
WITH US CNN'S SENIOR LEGAL
ANALYST AND FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR ELLIE HONING.
THEIR DEFENSE HAS EVOLVED,
RIGHT, BUT THERE ARE SOME
DISTINCT THEMES AND LET'S
DISCUSS HOW VALID THEY MAY OR
MAY NOT BE BASED ON THE EVIDENCE
THAT WE HAVE.
DEFENSE NUMBER ONE THEY'VE
ARGUED ALL THESE DOCUMENTS HAD
BEEN DECLASSIFIED.
>> LET'S START WITH WHAT WE
KNOW, JOHN.
FOR SURE WHEN THE FBI WENT INTO
MAR-A-LAGO THEY SEIZED BOXES
THAT WERE MARKED WITH CONTAINING
CONFIDENTIAL AND CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, UP TO AND ASKING
TS/SCI DOCUMENTS WHICH IS THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF CLASSIFICATION.
NOW, LEGALLY CONSTITUTIONALLY
THE PRESIDENT HAS EXTREMELY
BROAD, ARGUABLY UNLIMITED POWER
TO DECLASSIFY DOCUMENTS AT HIS L
YES, THERE ARE RULES,
REGULATIONS THAT KIND OF THING
BUT I THINK THE BETTER
CONSTITUTIONAL ARGUMENT IS THAT
IT'S UP TO THE PRESIDENT.
THE QUESTION HERE, THOUGH, IS
DID HE -- DID HE ACTUALLY
EXERCISE THAT CONSTITUTIONAL
POWER TO DECLASSIFY WHILE HE WAS
IN OFFICE?
NOW, I'VE SEEN NO CONVINCING
EVIDENCE THAT HE DID.
YOU WOULD EXPECT THERE TO BE
SOME SORT OF PAPER TRAIL AND IN
FACT YOU CRAFT THE CASE TO AN
EXTENT THE OTHER DAY WHEN JOHN
BOLTON THE FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISER TOLD YOU THIS,
THERE WAS NO STANDING ORDER.
I WAS NOT BRIEFED ON ANYTHING
LIKE THAT.
I NEVER HEARD T I NEVER SAW IT
IN OPERATION.
NEVER KNEW ANYTHING ABOUT T I
JUST THINK IT'S A COMPLETE
FICTION.
JOHN, MORE TO THE BIG POINT
HERE, THE THREE CRIMES THAT DOJ
ALLEGED IN THE DOCUMENTS THAT
GOT AT THE SEARCH WARRANT, NONE
OF THEM HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
WHETHER THE DOCUMENTS ARE
CLASSIFIED OR DECLASSIFIED AND
EVEN IF THEY WERE ANTICIPATING
THIS ARGUMENT SO IT DOESN'T
REALLY MATTER WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THOSE SPECIFIC
CRIMES.
>> ANOTHER DEFENSE THAT TRUMP
AND HIS ALLIES HAVE PUT FORWARD
IS THE FBI COULD HAVE ASKED
NICELY.
>> THAT ONE DOES NOT STAND UP.
FIRST OF ALL, CALLING THIS A
SEIZURE -- SAB THEY DIDN'T NEED
TO SEIZE ANYTHING, THEY BROKE
IN, SAYING THIS WAS A RAID, THAT
IS NONSENSE BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THIS WAS TAKEN TO AND APPROVED
BY A FEDERAL JUDGE, WE'VE SEEN
THE DOCUMENTS, HE SIGNED THE
FORMS, THESE ARE THE STANDARD
FORMS.
DONALD TRUMP WILL HAVE A CHANCE
TO CHALLENGE THIS IN THERE COMES
A DAY WHEN HE'S CHARGED.
THE WAY IT WOULD WORK, DOJ IF
THEY SEEK AN INDICTMENT THEN
DONALD TRUMP GETS THE PAPERWORK,
HE CAN GO TO COURT AND SAY THIS
SEARCH WAS DONE IN A WAY THAT
VIOLATES MY RIGHTS.
IF WE LOOK AT THE FACTS HERE,
THE TIMELINE, THIS NOTION THAT
THEY COULD HAVE HAD IT IF THEY
JUST ASKED NICELY REALLY DOES
NOT MEASURE UP.
BACK IN JANUARY NATIONAL
ARCHIVES THEY ASKED NICELY THEY
GOT SOME OF THE BOXES NOT ALL.
MAY AND JUNE DOJ ASKED NICELY
THEY SERVED A SUBPOENA, THEY GET
SOME MORE OF THE DOCUMENTS BUT
STILL NOT ALL AND FINALLY IN
AUGUST THEY EXECUTED THE SEARCH
WARRANT.
SO THIS NOTION THAT, WELL, THEY
JUST HAD TO ASK, THAT REALLY
DOESN'T STAND UP, EITHER.
>> I WILL TRY TO ARTICULATE THIS
OTHER DEFENSE THE BEST THAT I
UNDERSTAND IT BECAUSE IT'S A
LITTLE HARD.
SOMEHOW HE'S ARGUING THAT THE
DOCUMENTS TAKEN WERE COVERED BY
EITHER EXECUTIVE OR
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
>> THIS ONE IS REALLY A RED
HERRING.
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE ONLY APPLIES
TO CERTAIN COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND TOP
ADVISER NOT TO CRIMINAL-HE LATED
COMMUNICATIONS.
ATTORNEY/CLIENT PRIVILEGE IS OUT
OF LEFT FIELD THAT WOULD ONLY
APPLY BETWEEN TRUMP AND HIS
ATTORNEY.
EVEN IF THOSE ARGUMENTS APPLY, I
DON'T THINK THEY DO, YOU DON'T
GET TO TAKE THEM HOME WITH YOU.
IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU PERSONALLY
POSSESS THOSE DOCUMENTS.
>> AND THERE'S THIS SORT OF
FOURTH AREA THAT THEY ARE NOT
LEANING INTO, ELLIE, BUT MIGHT
MATTER HERE.
>> YEAH, SO EVERYONE IS SORT OF
FOCUSED ON DONALD TRUMP'S
DEFENSES.
I UNDERSTAND WHY.
BUT LET'S NOT MISS THE SORT OF
IMPORTANT FIRST POINT.
IN ANY CRIMINAL PROSECUTION DOJ
HAS THE BURDEN OF PROVING BEYOND
A REASONABLE DOUBT AND THE KEY
ISSUE IS GOING TO BE DONALD
TRUMP'S KNOWLEDGE AND INTENT.
DID HE KNOW WHAT WAS IN THOSE
BOXES AND DID HE HAVE THE
CRIMINAL INTENT REQUIRED BY THE
VARIOUS STATUTES TO BREAK THE
LAW?
A COUPLE OF IMPORTANT THINGS ON
THAT POINT.
WE LEARNED YESTERDAY REPORTING
FROM MAGGIE HABERMAN, "NEW YORK
TIMES," IS THAT DONALD TRUMP
SAID SOMETHING LIKE THEY'RE
MINE.
>> THEY'RE NOT THEIRS, THEY'RE
>> THAT WOULD GO TO KNOWLEDGE
AND INTENT.
WE KNOW THAT DOJ HAS SPOKEN WITH
PAT CIPOLLONE AND PAT PHILBIN, I
WOULD BE ASKING THEM QUESTIONS
THAT GO TO KNOWLEDGE AND INTENT.
DID DONALD TRUMP KNOW WHAT WAS
IN THOSE BOX AS SOON AS DID HE
KNOW ABOUT THEM BEING SENT TO
MAR-A-LAGO.
THAT COULD BE KEY EVIDENCE FOR
THE PROSECUTION'S CASE.
>> THERE ARE A FEW SENTENCES
THAT GO DIRECTLY TO THIS MAYBE
VERY IMPORTANT GOING FORWARD.
COULD BE PART OF THE AFFIDAVIT
WE MAY OR MAY NEVER SEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT.